you were out there you were out there
for over four hours last night with this
incredible group of people mingling with
the crowd it was a it was a blast and I
would actually I want to thank everybody
because you know yesterday watching the
40th anniversary panel it and then
thinking about just all what this means
to all of us I started getting really
scared it's really it's really scary
come out of doing this and coming out
last night get in to meet all you guys
feeling just the positivity feeling the
encouragement and just getting to
actually I don't know just to just meet
you guys and get to know you a little
bit it was it I did thank you we get
this is the best fan family in the world
man this is you guys to the fence and
you feel so good thank you
amazing alright so now we've gotten all
of the pleasantries out of the way I
have to ask you the question on
everybody's mind where are we at with
the last Jedi
we're actually so we're in
post-production we're still editing but
we're very far along we're doing quite
well and it's all coming together yeah
there was that a picture by the way
before can we go back for a second is
there a picture of you and no not that
that's you with these people we did that
there picture of you signing the
Millennium Falcon good idea that you
signing the actual Millennium Falcon is
a perk of the job that isn't so cool so
there I assume there are no close-up
shots of the Millennium Falcon anymore
huh no you can't yeah if you look very
closely on any of the flybys yeah
alright so Cathy what does Ryan bring in
terms of new style to the Star Wars
universe well I think you're already
getting a sense of it but I'm going to
embarrass him by saying that he is on
his way to standing alongside many of
the great filmmakers that I've had the
opportunity to work with
[Applause]
he has an amazing uniqueness to what he
does he also writes as beautifully as he
directs which is quite incredible and he
writes amazingly fierce and independent
women also got a great sense of humor
and that as everybody in this room knows
is so important to Star Wars so it's a
pretty fantastic package I should stop
talking after that and just leave the
stage I'm not everything is just down
hills after Thank You Kathy that means
all right so Ryan tell us about shooting
the movie the whole Pinewood connection
you know Star Wars has a history of
shooting in London talk about that well
I guess that we had the time of our
lives making this movie was such a
joyful experience from from top to
bottom and we were in shooting in
Pinewood Studios in England which to me
it was my first yeah it was my first
time being there and I know about you
guys but for me like growing up it was
like Pinewood Studios was like Camelot
or something it was like this mythical
place that you heard about with the
movies that you know Bond movies were
shot there and to actually set up camp
there and be able to come into work
every day it just added to this magical
experience the legacy really is insane
because I shot two films in London and
the only thing the crew ever wants to
talk about are the Star Wars films like
oh that's where the Millennium Falcon
was we're like we need to be setting up
for lunch now so Ryan you also spent
time in Ireland as on social media
how's Cleveland's like when I see
pictures like this this is Skellig right
that's Kelly and Dingle yeah that's it
we're in singles those are the locals
hair like amazed but do they like look
out the window like hey there's Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber I can't possibly
do my homework papa
that's terrible I rejoice on the locals
right I know I'm everybody Erland again
but like crazy yeah well it was I'll
tell you man because we were up and down
the west coast of Ireland and everywhere
we went and anyone who's in Ireland
right now who's watching this we miss
you guys we love you guys you guys were
so welcoming of us and this big unruly
film crew that came in and set up all
this stuff and you guys were just had so
much love for all of us and now we had
yeah we great time there and shot some
beautiful beautiful landscapes and just
some great stuff
speaking of shooting landscapes I hear
that you took a lot of pictures on set
is that correct yeah no that was so
there was something I realized at the
beginning of it I realized I had kind of
a front row seat for all this cool
behind-the-scenes stuff and I was
besides a set photographer I was like
the only person on set who could take
pictures and not get like tackled and
kicked in the face so I had I have this
is my warhorse this is my like a film
camera that I got right before looper
and when I was making looper I just had
this in my arm and I just shot a ton of
skills and
so I did the same thing on this movie I
just had this camera on my arm the
entire time and anything I saw was cool
I would just snap away at it these are
some of the shamans shots you see here
but I got I ended up taking like
thousands of pictures of the whole
process is the man that's when I get
that attitude like a really Lord and it
ends up being I mean it was it was fun
and it also at the end of this whole
experience because this is what you do
this you know this is a
once-in-a-lifetime experience just to
have all these memories captured and
this poor guy I feel so bad for that guy
someone's got to do it these are
incredible to the entire film with shots
I kept shouting that Stewart our second
they do is grabbing that thing I think
that's Stewart and I kept shouting
you're the forest Stewart you're the
forest Wow unbelievable so the entire
film was shot in black and white yeah we
haven't told Disney yet though so let's
keep that dick don't tweet that don't
tweet that Alan horn don't go there yes
you've heard it here first I would be
remiss not mentioning someone we all
miss and love the great Carrie Fisher
we saw her first
[Applause]
yeah yesterday I watched that incredible
tribute eyeballed then john williams
came out and i fell off before stopping
it was really incredible and i'd love to
hear from both of you guys what was it
like continuing to develop the great
princess now general Leia well it was
extraordinary needless to say Carrie is
remarkable in the movie I mean what Ryan
wrote and what she the performance she
ends up giving I think you guys are
going to find that an amazing tribute to
her talent yeah she I mean I yeah
Carrie I mean it was such a moving
tribute yesterday and I don't know if I
can add to that I I love I love her so
much man I just adore her and and I
connected with her first and foremost as
a writer you know she's a brilliant
writer as they incredible minds and we
like would sit on I go to her house we'd
sit on her bed for hours and go through
this script ng we just have these kind
of these kind of stream-of-consciousness
jazz poetry kind of like ad-lib sessions
and I would just scribble a my script
everything she said and then at the end
of six hours there would be like a four
word line of dialogue that would be like
the distillation all of all that that
was brilliant you know I'd be like oh my
god yeah I saw that piece yesterday
where she can remember every single line
that she did from all that was
incredible well she truly was ahead of
her time and led the way for what has
become a legacy of strong empowered
empowered heroine
hmm speaking of strong empowered hermit
two years ago at celebration in Anaheim
we were introduced to a new heroine a
new face who has now become part of the
iconic Star Wars lexicon someone I've
had the pleasure of working with getting
to know and harassing on a daily basis
please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
my heart is pounding thank you so much
oh oh hello Newman hello this is Daisy
Daisy Daisy Daisy I would love to put
the past behind us
it's not about my questions anymore it's
about their questions now you don't owe
me anything but you may want to think
twice because they seem like a very
aggressive crowd the billions of people
at home watching I'm sure would like
some of these questions answered as well
so I've got a couple of questions a
couple of questions I'd like to ask you
up to you whether or not you want to
answer are you and Luke related by blood
no to that one okay
are you a Skywalker is your name Rey
Skywalker
you can name Rey Kenobi
that's a popular women who doesn't know
their own last name can you imagine if I
went up to you and I said my entire name
is Josh good to meet you
you like the Madonna of jakku okay all
right you see we're getting nowhere if
you were getting nowhere Daisy let's all
start off with a simple question Daisy
did you enjoy working on the last Jedi
[Laughter]
you know I actually can tell you
something mmm yeah yeah a small amount I
have for you what I can say is in the
last Jedi and we go deeper into Ray's
story and and what is very apparent from
where we left off in the force awakens
and where we begin with the last Jedi is
Raya has a certain expectation as to
what she might be getting from Luke and
what that might entail and as a lot of
people know it's so difficult when you
meet your heroes because it might not be
what you expect there isn't
amazing that's why I'm alright one thing
that one team that's it but I will say
that picture was shot in Ireland we had
the most incredible time it was honestly
it was very nerve-wracking going back to
the second time because the first time
around I didn't quite know what I was
doing I was just bumbling along and
luckily I had cast the enjoy each and
every one as a wonderful kind of cushion
around me um the the response to the
force awakens was amazing but well um
but coming back the second time I felt a
certain responsibility and I was like oh
I should know I'm doing now and I kind
of don't
but luckily Ryan's writing is beautiful
the film I think is great and we had the
best time
amazing you know I've spoken to you
about this before as a father of two
girls I feel and I think a lot of this
is due to you as well I feel incredible
about the fact that there are all of
these strong empowered females now
inhabiting the Star Wars world in the
mold of Leia what is it like coming back
here two years later being with the fans
when they first got to meet you now they
all have your action figures they all
have your dresses some of them have
you're not all of them like what you
know what is it like knowing that you
are a part of this history now
well I will say is and people kept kind
of congratulating me on that and that
was Michael Larry and JJ and Kathy and
all of the story developers at Lucasfilm
that who created ray I was just lucky
enough to be able to embody that it's
it's insane it's like it kind of goes
like I kind of forget it happened and
then like I can see people wearing a
costume I'm like oh my god this is real
it's really wonderful and especially
people who have little girls and the way
that people talk about ray in the way
that this film has affected them is
amazing so I'm very happy to be part of
it can I say Josh actually so I mean
that's very gracious of Daisy and she's
very right and obviously she's not rare
she's a great actor is playing ray but
so much of the stuff that
people respond to in that character and
having gotten to know Daisy and gunning
to work with gun to work with over the
past few years the tenacity and the
bravery and the humor and the depth and
so many of the things that make little
kids want to be Rey just like the things
that people looked up to and Leia came
from carry those things are Daisy really
closed up by the way my daughter's
favorite action figure is the Ray doll
and I take put that away she won't
answer any question put it away
all right without divulging too much
obviously what are you most excited
about for fans to experience in the last
Jedi I think what we're all very excited
for Luke's first
[Applause]
I will say that is definitely me me me
me me me
[Music]